[Music]
okay everyone so this is my spoiler free
review of the latest james bond
installment no time to die this is the
last film daniel craig is doing as the
notorious james bond i was fortunate
enough to be invited to a screening for
this
and i got to see it on imax and what i
had done before this film is binge watch
all of the james bond films today on
craig beforehand to be prepared
one i'm really happy i did that because
there is a lot in this movie that throws
back especially to the last film but
stuff even that throws back to casino
royale so make sure you refresh on these
films in particular spectre you really
gotta refresh because there's a lot
tying into that which actually
surprising but i do think works i think
what this film does really well is tie
up previous plot lines that were left
loose from other james bond films and
kind of honored the whole series with
daniel craig as a whole and let it have
a nice bow here
i went into this film with literally no
expectations because for me with the
daniel craig films it's been like you
know casino royale really good then
quantum soul is not so great and sky
fall amazing and then spectre was like
eh
so but i you know you had to think like
okay something's got to give because
it's kind of in every other film for
daniel craig here that's successful
and really good and then it happened
again where with no time to die i was so
impressed with this movie um what i was
most excited about was kerry joji
fukunaga
directing this thing because i loved how
he did true detective season one he's a
talented director it was interesting to
see him do something in a big budget
film like this and he doesn't disappoint
this was the best paced bond film to me
it was the only bond film out of the
bunch with daniel craig that i didn't
feel bored in any points
it was two hours and 45 minutes that
felt like an hour and a half to me and
what kerry does so well as a director
here is he
just keeps it moving but every single
action sequence is so well thought out
to make it unique and different than
typical bond action sequences and it has
the best opening sequence of any bond
films
hands down and i argue out of this
daniel craig saga here that it has the
best third act out of any of those films
so
where i would compare it to is my
favorite was skyfall but what i thought
this is better than skyfall was that
i wasn't crazy about the third act of
skyfall and i thought it really slowed
down and got boring but this didn't feel
that at all i felt like the whole movie
i was on the edge of my seat really into
it and what was most important was the
focal point of this film was that it
would give daniel craig a nice emotional
send-off and it does go there people
will be emotional with this film and
that was such an important payoff when
you're closing out when people get so
attached to an actor who's playing james
bond that you give him a rifle send off
that gives him enough time now you're
gonna see
things about this film that weren't so
great even though i'm praising it so
much was that rami malek
he's great but
his character is underwritten a bit so
it's not gonna go down really is a
historic bond villain he's very paper
thin but he does a great job and he's
fun to watch on the screen and another
thing was it's bittersweet because on a
day armas
literally
is amazing in this film like scene
stealer but she's not in the film really
that much at all so you're like at one
point like
where is she like
this was someone who just was amazing
and apart and there's it's bizarre how
little she is in this movie so that was
a big complaint of mine but going to the
positives again han zimmer doing the
score this time around amazing and he
does cool things with classic bond
themes so i really appreciate that and
he really is another point to why you
feel kind of pumped up during this movie
and
it has twists that are successfully
landed here that you don't really see
coming and
again i think that it's the perfect
movie for it's gonna sound corny saying
this but like you could take your dad
and mom to this and they're not gonna be
confused they're gonna enjoy it just as
much as you do it is truly a successful
entertaining action flick and if you're
not really into a lot of action
you know this isn't really the bond for
you and
it really is centered on how great the
action sequences are plus getting again
big character emotional payoffs for
daniel craig and james bond
now
i was
a little disappointed in the humor
there's very little humor in this film
so
the wit's supposed to be taken down with
daniel craig anyway as james bond that's
not really his forte as james bond but
here it could have used a little more
humor it doesn't even really try and
that's surprising is you got phoebe
waller's bridge here who is great with
sharp wit writing on this thing you
don't really kind of feel her script
writing come out in this besides that
though again the new characters you're
gonna like the old characters get enough
screen time that you're happy about it
and it's
really just
an exciting
big
tentpole movie to come out when it's
desperately needed for theaters at the
moment and i think it will be divisive
though for die hard bond fans i think
some people are going to be
maybe not as into the plot as you would
expect but it got me but i could see why
some wouldn't and i don't want to spoil
anything so i won't go in that too much
detail but you know lower expectations
you're going to see a lot of reviews
praising it today including mine i'm
giving this thing a 9.2 it's my favorite
bond filling by the daniel craig bunch
but i could totally see the argument for
skyfall or christina royale being your
favorite over this one it's close like
it's so you could flip it back and forth
like it's just gonna be kind of
remembered in that tier of those three
bond films of craig and we can kind of
forget about quantum souls and spectre
but i'm happy that it's not in that
other bottom tier with those two and
that it's going to be remembered in that
and i think people are just going to
debate between skyfall casino royale and
no time to die and i think either
argument is valid i don't think it's
like so much better in my opinion than
skyfall which is my favorite i think
it's a little better so i'm happy and
that's great to end a series of five
movies on that for daniel craig and it
leaves you excited for where this is
going to go next so when you see the
film let me know what you think comment
below and let me know if you plan on
seeing and let me know your thoughts
just in general about the bond films
that have come out down craig and if you
like them or not i'd love to hear your
thoughts on that as well oh and also i
want to mention love billy eilish's song
here in the opening credits the opening
credits sequence is really good too so
you won't be disappointed with that as
well so please follow me at steverlyshow
on twitter and instagram for more of me
and if you really like what i do here
please subscribe so you don't miss one
of my reviews i do movie reviews tv
reviews i also do celebrating videos as
well so you want to check that out and
i'll see you next time